Wow, Nvidia.
You know, in a way I'm actually impressed.
Your sheer lack of concern for any of your mainstream customers, it's kind of an achievement.
Like you're in a race with Wizards of the Coast to see who can tick off their fanbase
the fastest, and you're out to prove you'll do anything to win.
I mean, Nvidia's practically admitted they'd rather rely on software tricks than give us
faster hardware, and the 40 series is not just overpriced.
It's more like hate priced.
And the thing is, guys, we know that getting outraged is not going to do anything.
And you know it's not going to do anything.
The 4060 Ti was panned by critics and the community alike, and still costs $400 somehow.
But if you want us to get mad, then okay, let's get mad, because the RTX 4060 is yet
another nail in the world's most overpriced coffin.
And we're tired of it.
And we're also tired of not telling you about our sponsor, Super Micro, the newest additions
to Super Micro's H13 servers are here, powered by AMD's epic 9000 for processors with up
to 128 cores, an amount of cores that we're not sure is legal.
Get blazing fast performance that handles even the most memory intensive workloads.
Click the link below and upgrade your infrastructure today.
Like its bigger titanium year brother, the 4060 is built on Nvidia's AD106 GPU and has
8 gigs of GDDR6 memory.
So what are we losing when we downgrade to a feebler metal?
Well, for starters, 29% of our CUDA cores, for the main cores, 33% fewer ray tracing
and tensor cores, and for dessert, a sweet $100 price cut that makes it, am I reading
this correctly, less expensive than the last gen card it replaces.
But it's not all roses.
Those core counts aren't just lower than the 4060 Ti, they're lower than the last
gen 3060.
Also lower than last gen is the memory bus width, still at a piddly 128 bits.
Oh, and don't forget, they halved the number of PCIe lanes, which could cause a bottleneck
for those still on PCIe gen 3 platforms.
But look, sayeth Nvidia, the clock speeds are up, and there was a big bump to L2 cache
to make up for the dire lack of memory bandwidth.
Spoiler alert, it doesn't.
To prove it, we put the 4060 and its competition through a brutal series of tests, 1100 total
tests.
That's right, the labs is in full swing, baby!
We've included a bunch of cards that are still topping the Steam hardware charts, the
best of AMD's bang for the buck lineup, and an Intel ARC A750 for good measure.
And as you've probably already figured out from the specs, this is not a 4K card.
So let's get these results out of the way quick.
The 4060 only touched 60 average FPS in F1, and was anywhere from meh to barely playable
in our other titles.
You could have a decent experience in older games, or with settings dialed back to medium
or low, but if you want to play on high, you'll have to resort to techniques some consider
to be unnatural.
Sticking with pure rasterization performance for now though, let's talk 1080p.
Nvidia made it very clear with the 4060 Ti that they were not trying to make a card that
is significantly more capable than its predecessor, and with the 4060, Nvidia has extended their
not trying streak.
In Cyberpunk 2077, the 4060 fails to outpace the 3060 Ti, which is like the one card you'd
hope this thing at least ties with, right?
To add insult to injury, it even falls behind the now $30-$50 cheaper RX7600 from Team Red.
Then we see the same story in F122, where the 4060 sits just 10% ahead of its last-gen
direct counterpart, the 3060.
The real star of the show then, again, is the last-gen 6700 XT, which cranks out 42%
more frames than the 4060, and at the time of writing can be purchased for just $10 more.
In The Last of Us Part 1, the 4060 at least beats its direct Team Red competitor, RX 6700,
but again fails to overcome the 3060 Ti.
And the more tests we ran, the more true our observations became.
This thing is so bad that if I didn't know any better, I'd say Nvidia didn't even
bother to benchmark to price this thing accordingly.
To peak at Vulcan performance, we included Red Dead Redemption 2, where the story mostly
stays the same, but the Arc A750 shows up with some impressive performance.
Then in Forza, the 4060 finally eeks its way ahead of the 3060 Ti.
Yay, I guess.
And Returnal just confirms what we already know again.
Overall, the 4060 offers very little in performance over its direct Team Red competitor, and it
does so at a 20% premium in price.
I hope the story changes when we look at 1440p.
Nope, we actually see the gap between the 3060 Ti and the 4060 increase in several games,
and the gap between Team Red and Nvidia gets no wider.
And just like we saw in our review of the 4060 Ti, the 67 XT is far and away the most
sensible option for gamers looking for max bang for the buck, thanks in no small part
to its 12GB of VRAM.
To be clear, 8GB is fine for most things today, but that's unlikely to stay true forever.
Unlike the pricing on water bottles at lttstore.com, they're the same price no matter what size
you like, and mystery bottles are 10 bucks off if you don't care about the color.
But wait, maybe there's a justification for all of this.
A master plan.
I mean, we're five years into Nvidia's graphics reinvented, ray traced future.
Can a cheaper 60 series card give mainstream gamers a taste of that technology?
As it turns out, cutting so many RT cores negates any generational gain over the 3060
Ti.
Even if there is an improvement over the 3060.
At least it still beats any of the AMD cards in its price bracket, but the frame rate hit
from turning on ray tracing even at 1080p just might not be worth the bump in visual
fidelity for many gamers.
Of course, Nvidia does also have DLSS and frame gen.
And we do have to give credit where it's due here.
When set to the quality preset, in most games DLSS, Nvidia's AI upscaling technique, is
near indistinguishable from standard rendering.
If you know where to look, you can find visual anomalies, but it's gotten good enough over
the last few years that you pretty much need to be looking for them, and the performance
gains are very substantial.
This is where Nvidia wants to steer the discussion, and for good reason.
Using DLSS at 1440p, we are seeing excellent gains in performance with the 4060 finally
convincingly pulling ahead of last generation, thanks to one of DLSS' latest tricks, frame
gen.
Frame gen smooths animations by creating new frames in between the natively rendered ones.
Though it should be noted that frame generation comes with downsides, like higher latency
and also just not being magic.
For example, with frame gen, 4K gaming is possible on these cards, but we know from
our test that if you have less than 30 native FPS, it's really not the best playing experience.
You can go see our experiments in the video linked in the description.
With that said, in older games or at lower settings, I could see gamers using Nvidia's
machine learning AI tomfoolery to run this thing at 4K.
The problem is it's limited to like a couple dozen games, so meh.
Moving on to productivity, a traditional strong point for Nvidia, Blender sees the 4060 look
fairly capable for a mainstream card.
And the same goes for specviewperf, where it's clear that the 128-bit memory bus is
a real problem.
Though it's worth noting, this benchmark is getting a little long in the tooth.
We are also working on getting some results from DaVinci Resolve, but at the time of review,
driver issues stood in our way.
Speaking of issues, what about the issue of expensive power?
Whether gaming or running full-borne applications, like the rest of the 40 series, the 4060 sips
power.
F122 brings it all the way up to its rated power, but that's just 115 watts, a significant
drop from its tie-clad brother and even less than AMD's 7600.
In fact, it's less than a 3050.
If the price of power is a concern where you live, then the 4060 actually could offer a
decent value.
This is probably where the card shines its brightest.
And thanks to sipping power, the thermals on these Asus dual cards we got for testing
are also great, with temps never exceeding 73 degrees on the hotspot.
Which was kind of a lot of words to say, Nvidia doesn't care about you when they can't
book enough fab capacity to serve the far more lucrative AI customers that rocketed
their valuation beyond a trillion dollars earlier this month.
But we gave this wet fart of a GPU a full review treatment anyway, in hopes that sometime
in the future, it'll come down in price and make sense to buy.
That's just the best we can do, which we know is kind of lame.
We said we were going to get mad today, but we're just out of gas at this point.
And I feel like a lot of you must be in the same boat.
I mean, at a certain point, Nvidia is going to drive their customers past anger all the
way to apathy.
And if there's one piece of advice that we can give Nvidia, just don't let that happen.
No, at least if someone's angry at me, I still know they care.
They're invested in the relationship.
They're holding on, hoping it's going to get better.
If they stop giving a crap, that's when I'll know that the end is coming.
But you know what you didn't see coming?
This segue to our sponsor.
Delete me.
In a time when companies are constantly sharing your personal information online without your
consent, it's easy to get discouraged.
Feels like there's nothing you can do until you hear about the sponsor of this video.
Delete me.
Delete me will help you find hundreds of online profiles sharing your personal information,
which could be used by scammers to hit you with a barrage of robocalls and spam emails.
And in more extreme cases, it could even lead to identity theft or fraud, which are bad.
Removing all this information by yourself would be a huge task and take many hours.
But with delete me software and team of experts, it can be done in minutes.
On average, delete me finds and removes over 2000 pieces of data per customer in their
first two years.
So if you want to get your personal information removed from search results on the web, go
to joindeleteme.com slash LinusTechTips and use code LTT for 20% off.
If you guys enjoyed this video, why not watch our review of the RX 7600?
Especially with the recent price drop, it's become even more compelling.
And there are some cards featured in that review that we couldn't include here.